D
PUNISHING ORDINARY RUSSIANS
WITHOUT PUTIN AND HIS ALLIES.
DOCTOR, WASN'T INEVITABLE FROM
DAY ONE?
>> THE SANCTIONS RARELY WORK TO
CHANGE THE BEHAVIOR OF TARGET
STATES.
SURE, YOU CAN PUNISH THE PEOPLE
OF THE STATE BUT YOU WILL NEVER
CAUSE STATE LEADERS TO GIVE UP
WHAT THEY CONSIDERED TO BE SO
IMPORTANT TO THEIR VITAL
NATIONAL INTERESTS.
IN THE CASE OF RUSSIA, THAT'S
THE SITUATION IN UKRAINE.
OFTEN WHAT YOU GET IS A KIND OF
FEEL GOOD RESPONSE.
THIS IS FEEL-GOOD ACTIVITY WHEN
OTHER TYPES OF INTERVENTIONS ARE
DEEMED TO BE TO COSTLY.
IN MANY CASES, AT OFTEN TIMES
WHEN THEY ARE SUCCESSFUL THEY
JUST TAKE A LOT OF TIME.
IT ISN'T NECESSARILY SOMETHING
SO VITAL LIKE YOUR GRAIN.
>> Laura: THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS THE REVENUE FROM THE
FOSSIL FUEL EXPORTS HAVE
EXCEEDED WHAT THE COUNTRY IS
SPENDING ON THE WAR IN UKRAINE
ACCORDING TO REPORTS AND THEN
"NEW YORK TIMES."
THEY'RE MAKING A HUGE AMOUNT OF
MONEY AND CHINA AS I SAID BACK
IN MARCH, ONCE WE KNEW THEY'RE
GOING TO BE BUYING OIL FROM
RUSSIA, THAT WAS GAME OVER.
I MEAN, THIS IS ALL KIND OF
RIDICULOUS.
THIS IS LIKE KABUKI THEATER IN A
WAY.
>> THIS IS YET ANOTHER CASE OF
THE KIND OF UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES WE SEE FROM
MISGUIDED ACTIONS.
WE HAVE HEARD ABOUT THESE YACHTS
THAT WE HAVE SEIZED AND THEN WE
HAVE TO PAY FOR THEIR UPKEEP.
IF THAT'S THE KIND OF SMALL
EXAMPLE, BUT WE SEE THIS IN
TERMS OF OIL PRICES, FOOD
PRICES, AND THEN YOU CAN SEE THE
UNITED STATES TAKE HIM A LOOK,
WE HAVE TO PROVIDE SUBSIDIES FOR
GLOBAL FOOD ASSISTANCE.
IT'S A CASE IN WHICH THESE ARE
VERY PREDICTABLE.
AND SCHOLARS HAVE BEEN STUDYING
THIS FOR DECADES AND FINDING
THAT SANCTIONS ARE OFTENTIMES
NOT VERY HELPFUL.
AGAIN, VERY PREDICTABLE.
REALLY THAT'S TYPICAL OF WHAT WE
HAVE SEEN FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION.
ARE POLICIES THAT SOUND LIKE
THEY'RE GOING TO BE HELPFUL TO
THE AMERICAN TAXPAYER OR PEOPLE
ABROAD TO COME UP THEY ACTUALLY
SHOOT OURSELVES IN THE FOOT.
>> Laura: I THOUGHT THE WHOLE
SEIZING THE YACHT THING WAS
SUCH -- AGAIN, IT WAS KIND OF
CHOREOGRAPHED THEATER.
YOU'LL TAKE THE BIG YACHTS AND
THAT WILL SHOW THEM.
BUT IT DID NOTHING AND NOW WE
HAVE TO PAY AS YOU SAID FOR THE